[Musik]
so
so werden auch die frau bundesminister
das gab ihr recht
frau
bundesmitteln die feldscheune des genfer
zentrums
8 uhr die militärmusik niederösterreich
eine ehrung zum gestellt durch die garde
die stabsabteilung abteilung
weiterentwicklung der abteilung aber
schärfer kontrollieren und im dienst
betrieben also erzählt des traditions-
tages angetreten
[Musik]
frau bundesminister betreibt meldet sich
hat
das ganze
wäre zu schön
hier zu sein
das ganze parade gut
das ganze hat
ihre zu
ehren zu lassen
so flaggenparade das ganze recht
flagge hissen
[Musik]
das ganze parade
heute ist eine besonders große anzahl
von ehrengästen der einladung gefolgt
und ich bitte um ihr verständnis dass
ich in der gebotenen zeit nicht alle
einzeln begrüßen kann es ist eine
besondere freude die vom
bundesministerium für landesverteidigung
magistra klaudia tanner bei uns begrüßen
zu dürfen
ein herzliches willkommen dem
abgeordneten zum europäischen parlament
diplom ingenieur alexander bern huber
in vertretung der landeshauptmann von
niederösterreich und auch als vertreter
des niederösterreichischen landtag ist
darf ich abgeordneten zum
niederösterreichischen landtag und
bürgermeister der garnisonsstadt
korneuburg christian gibt begrüßen sowie
die abgeordneten zum nationalrat frau
melanie arazim und herrn andreas mini
es freut uns stellvertretend für alle
ressort angehörigen den
stellvertretenden chef des generalstabes
generalmajor und magister rudolf
striedinger zu begrüßen
ein herzliches grüß gott den vertretern
der geistlichkeit herrn militär kaplan
magister magister pater jakob stoiber
für die katholische militärseelsorge und
dem stadtpfarrer von kanal magister
stephan kohler
ich darf sie bitten ab jetzt dann erst
am ende der begrüßung wieder applaus zu
spenden ich darf in vertretung des
kommandanten der cyber kräfte den über
leitungs verantwortlichen der direktion
ik die jungs selber oberst er im bus
technik recht herzlich begrüßen ebenso
die überleitung verantwortliche und
leiterin der direktion acht favorisiert
noch der dr silbers paradies für die
akademien und schulen begrüße ich für
die theresianischen militärakademie
stellvertretend den stellt verdienten
akademie kommen dann regiert man ist
dann ist der franz hohler in vertretung
des kommandanten der flieger und
bedrucken schule herrn oberst magister
minister markus wachter und den mit der
führung betrauten kommandanten der
führungsunterstützung schule oberst
michael hofmann ich freue mich den
deutschen verteidigungsattaché in
österreich oberst im generalstab in
köthen den schweizer
verteidigungsattaché oberst im
generalstab
usa und den serbischen
verteidigungsattaché oberst im
generalstab salkovic sowie den
verteidigungsattaché in österreich im
verteidigungs- adresse in washington
generale magister minister norbert huber
bei uns willkommen zu heißen ich begrüße
die militärkommandanten von
niederösterreich bringt ihr magister
martina beck ich freue mich willkommen
zu heißen die präsidentin des
landesgerichts korneuburg magistra
andrea hahn und den leitenden
staatsanwalt der staatsanwaltschaft
korneuburg dr karl schober für die
bezirkshauptmannschaften den
bezirkshauptmann des bezirks korneuburg
magister andreas strobel sowie
stellvertretend für alle bürgermeister
die bürgermeisterin von leobendorf frau
magdalena bator ein
kameradschaftliches willkommen
stellvertretend für alle leitungen
komponenten dem leiter des amtes für
rüstung und wehrtechnik bringt ihr mann
ist am italienisch und den verführung
betrauten kommandanten luftunterstützung
oberst georg klein
die gute vernetzung des arbeitsjahres
zentrums im internationalen bereich
beweist die anwesenheit ausländischer
gäste und so ist es mir eine besondere
freude aus deutschland begrüßen zu
dürfen den kommandeur des abc apa
kommandos der bundeswehr oberst stefan
zahlung weiterer darf ich von der
waffengattung abc begrüßen oberst otto
strele oberstleutnant michael eich hübel
oberst norbert katzer oberst stefan kurz
und naja peter wittenberg
stellvertretend für die
blaulichtorganisationen begrüße ich
kameradschaftlich für die rettung den
landesrettungskommandant wolfgang
frühwirth für die polizei den bezirks
polizei konnten von korneuburg
oberstleutnant dr siegfried krise für
die justiz den leiter der justizanstalt
oberst wolfgang pirner für die
bergrettung niederösterreich den
landesleiter dr matthias kern oscar
sowie die feuerwehr tin bezirks
komponenten landes feuer landesfeuerwehr
rat wilfried kargen ich begrüße ebenso
den vorsitzenden des teams stecken
ausschusses wie zu erleichtern und
alexander hirsch als vertretung partner
begrüße ich aus dem bundesministerium
für digitalisierung und
wirtschaftsstandort den referatsleiter
der nationalen behörde für chemiewaffen
konvention und nokia kontrolle diplom
ingenieur carl lewis für die tüv aus der
akademie den geschäftsführer herrn
magister christian baier und für die
seibersdorf laber gmbh vordiplom
menschen der doktor martin schweiger die
verbundenheit mit dem kommando zeigt die
anwesende zahlreiche offiziere im
ruhestand und so heiß ich willkommen den
ehemaligen generalinspekteur ein general
in ruhe kabelnetzen um den ehemaligen
kommandanten der arbeitsjahre schule und
abwehrchef didier in ruhe norbert
fürstenhof ein herzliches willkommen den
abgeordneten und vereinen von der
freiwilligen feuerwehr strasshof ihren
hauptpreis inspector lohnsumme von der
vereinigung ist richard reese keeper den
bereits länder vize leiterin in ruhe
reinhard opitz vom münsterischen
kameradschaftsbund dem präsidenten des
landesverbandes oberstes intendanz
dienstes ade magister doktor heinsberger
und den obmann des stadtverbandes
korneuburg reinhard graf sowie vom
verein forum arbeitet sie ab dem
präsidenten des höheren liga
fachdienstes bernhard praxis sowie alle
angetretenen mitglieder
traditionsverbände
abschließend darf ich alle angehörigen
des arbeitspensums und gäste zu diesem
festakt recht herzlich begrüßt
sie können jetzt bin arbeite dem
traditionsmarsch des arbeitsmarkts
zentrums mutig und hilfsbereit danach
die ansprache des kommandanten des
arbeitsjahres zentrums oberst des
generalstabs ministerien schlechter und
die grußworte der landeshauptfrau
überbracht durch den
landtagsabgeordneten christian gehen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
hoch verehrte frau bundesminister hohe
geistlichkeit
geschätzte ehren und festgäste
angehörige des abwehrzentrums und von
astro
unserer tradition star begründet sich
genau am heutigen tage
heute vor 36 jahren kam es im
kernkraftwerk von tschernobyl zu einem
unfall dessen schreckliche auswirkungen
auch in österreich bis heute und darüber
hinaus andauern werden
eigentlich kennt wirklich unbeschwert
anlass für einen traditionsbank
warum haben wir diesen gewählt
weil dieser tag oder dieser anlass der
erste große einsatz der abc abwehr des
bundesheeres der zweiten republik
markiert
damals waren wir ziemlich einzigen die
eine verstrahlung detektieren und
fahrzeuge waren und personen die
kontaminierung konnten
und viele weitere einsätze sollten noch
folgen
chemiewaffen vernichtung im irak in den
1990 er jahren
antrags einsätze in österreich in den
frühen 2000er jahren und über 13
internationale einsätze in den bereichen
retten und bergen sowie der
trinkwasseraufbereitung als austria
forces disaster relief unit kurz acht
wochen
für die internationale truppe der
vereinten nationen im libanon stellen
wir seit über zehn jahren den
brandschutz sicher
unsere
absoluten profis dabei die kp kompanie
fehlt heute nach mehreren erfolgreichen
nationalen und internationalen qualitäts
audi zwar diese kompanie letztes jahr
teil der schnellen eingreifkräfte der
europäischen union kurz eu battlegroup
und befindet sich nun in der
vorbereitung für den nächsten einsatz im
libanon ab juni
die letzten zwei jahre haben auch uns
hier enorm gefordert
zu beginn der pandemie wann wird 2020 in
der ersten einheiten die neben der
forschung und der medizin zum einsatz
kamen es wurden dann letztendlich über
600 einsätze für die abwehrkräfte des
bundesheeres die aus dem arbeitsmarkt
zentrum heraus zu planen zu steuern
durchzuführen und wissenschaftlich zu
begleiten waren der prominenteste war
wohl der einsatz in den verteilerzentren
der post wo gerade in dieser zeit so
wichtige paketversand zu versagen drohte
und gleichzeitig haben wir es geschafft
unsere ausbildungen auch unter den
strengen schutz verordnungen der
pandemie aufrechtzuerhalten und die
wissenschaftlichen grundlagen
entsprechend weiterzuentwickeln
seit zwei monaten nun müssen wir erleben
dass der krieg den kaum noch jemand für
möglich gehalten hätte wieder auf den
europäischen kontinent zurückgekehrt ist
auch wenn derzeit eine direkte gefahr
von kampfhandlungen in österreich
auszuschließen ist können abc fahren in
der ukraine durch personen und wetter
nach österreich vertragen werden und so
zu einer zumindest indirekten bedrohung
für uns werden
wir am ehesten sind darauf vorbereitet
und beurteilen permanent die
gefahrenlage und das damit verbundene
risiko für unser land und seine bewohner
dabei fließen unsere beurteilungen auch
in die politischen entscheidungsebene 1
dabei wesentlicher teil unseres erfolges
ist unser innovativer und kooperativer
geist
genauso wie abc gefahren keinerlei
grenzen oder strukturen respektieren so
können auch wir in der zusammenarbeit
kaum grenzen die kooperation mit über 70
partnern erweist sich immer wieder als
unabdingbar für uns besonders unsere
kooperation mit dem arbeitsjahr der
command oder deutschen bundeswehr und
dem kompetenzzentrum abc kam ihr der
schweizer armee gewährleisten eine
nahezu nahtlose zusammenarbeit
und auch in unseren nachbarländern
erkennt man die wachsende bedeutung der
abc abwehr oberst salou kommandeur das
arbeitsjahr kommandos der deutschen
bundeswehr stellt gerade in der nähe
berlins ein neues zusätzliches abc
abwehr regimenter auf und verantwortet
gleichzeitig den einsatz der deutschen
kameraden zur verstärkung der nato
kräfte im baltikum
oberst platter aus der schweiz kann
heute leider nicht wieder uns sein weil
er ein projekt zur integration von
verschiedenen organisationen zum
sicherheitsverbund schweiz koordiniert
militärische konflikte werden immer mehr
im zivilen urbanen umfeld aufgetragen
das können wir schmerzlich und de facto
online in der ukraine und auch anderen
jüngsten militärischen konflikten
entnehmen dabei ist die
wahrscheinlichkeit einer freisetzung von
arbeitskräften
gefahrenstoffen mit einem urbanen umfeld
ebenfalls gestiegen vorbei sind die
zeiten
wo diese freisetzung lediglich auf
schlachtfeldern fernab jeglicher
zivilisation anzunehmen waren
solche tödliche freisetzungen finden
immer öfter auch ohne und unabhängig von
einem kriegszustand statt umso mehr
haben wir uns in den letzten jahren auch
darauf vorbereitet und weiterentwickelt
dabei wird die zusammensteht
zusammenarbeit verschiedenster
organisationen macht deren stärken immer
wichtiger den abc gefahren bekennen wie
bereits erwähnt keine grenzen oder
befindlichkeiten
wir sind dafür vorbereitet wir haben uns
als verlässlicher partner bewiesen und
können der seitens der politik auch noch
viel mehr genutzt werden
persönlich bin ich aber immer wieder
überrascht dass unsere ausgestreckte
hand
offensichtlich aus befindlichkeiten
motiviert auch ausgeschlagen wird
für die zukunft haben wir noch viel vor
ein wichtiger meilenstein wird die
anmeldung und weiterentwicklung von
astro als schnelle eingriff kraft der
europäischen union im bereich der
katastrophenhilfe sein unsere scheinbar
nur militärischer fähigkeiten sind
äußerst gefragt und würden ganz
wesentliche lücken schließen ich erwarte
bereits täglich sehnsüchtig grünes licht
aus dem ministerium damit wir die
eilmeldung in brüssel vornehmen können
besonders nachhaltig wird die
realisierung des arbeitsmarktes seien
eine sonderfinanzierung in der höhe von
100 millionen euro wurde ein budget
gesetz verankert und durch uns
entsprechend geplant jetzt sind wir
bereits in der phase der umsetzung
neue schutzmasken neue schutzanzüge und
messgeräte werden den individuellen abc
schutz aller österreichischen soldaten
enorm steigern neue messgeräte und
spezialfahrzeuge werden die abc
spezialisten gehörig in deren kampf wert
steigern und ein neues notwendiges
werkstätten gebäude wird dann auch
sicherstellen dass das so wichtige und
wertvolle gerät auch repariert und
serviciert werden kann
ich möchte mich hier bei unserer
bundesministerin aufrichtig bedanken und
gleichzeitig versuchen bei der gerade
der mühsamen und komplexen umsetzung
notwendige unterstützung nicht
nachzulassen damit wir die geplante
erneuerung auf effektiv und effizient
über die zielgerade bringen können
das alles haben in erster linie sie
geschätzte soldatinnen und soldaten
sowie mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter
geschaffen
weil sie jeden tag bestens ausgebildet
und topmotiviert ihren job erledigen
können wir voller stolz den heutigen tag
begehen und endlich auch wieder feiern
wenn sie zu jeder tages und nachtzeit
einsatzbereit sind und ihren
untergebenen vorbilder sind können wir
alle einander vertrauen und diese
einzigartige exzellenz erreichen
mutig und hilfsbereit
ist weit mehr als nur eine marketing
überschrift es ist unsere innere
einstellung und überzeugung wir unseren
dienst versehen
dass ich sie dabei führen und begleiten
darf ist mir jeden tag eine große freude
verantwortung und ehre
es lebe das abwehrzentrum
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau bundesminister der
kommandant wird die kameradinnen ehren
und festgäste seit fast 120 jahren ist
kein neuburg garnisonsstadt ist die
stadt und die kaserne miteinander
verbunden mehr denn je sind wir auf die
expertise und unterstützung des abc
abwehrzentrums angewiesen bei der
bekämpfung der pandemie
den einsatz bei der brandbekämpfung am
truppenübungsplatz einsteigt oder wenn
man die expertise im rahmen der ukraine
krise denkt hier überall ist das abc
abwehrzentrum an vorderster front aktiv
für viele ist das bundesheer in karlburg
sicht und erlebbar
hier ist es auch da kommen dann
federführend aktiv und auch viele
einsatzorganisationen die den abc abwehr
zentrum im austausch sind gibt es viele
positive rückmeldungen
es geht um ein sicherheitsgefühl der
bevölkerung dass in unserer region sehr
positiv wahrgenommen wird dazu kommen
noch die lehrgänge die als know how
transfer für ganz österreich und darüber
hinaus stehen
ich möchte mich bei dir frau
bundesminister sehr herzlich für die
geplanten investitionen im abc
abwehrbereich in korneuburg und
überhaupt dann bedanken und kann nur
beipflichten dass gerade jetzt unser
bundesheer eine ausgezeichnete
versicherungs polizist
starb ihnen auch die besten grüße
unserer landeshauptfrau johanna
mikl-leitner überbringen und mich in
ihren namen und in meinen eigenen namen
behindern herkommen da bei ihren
mitarbeiterinnen für ihren einsatz und
ihre unterstützung für unsere region für
niederösterreich herzlich danken
neben den schon erwähnten themen gibt es
auch weiter herausforderungen denen wir
uns gerade gemeinsam widmen hier darf
ich als beispiel das blackout erwin
ich darf dem abc abwehrzentrum zum
heutigen traditions- tag herzlich
gratulieren freue mich auch weiterhin so
gute zusammenarbeit es lebe das abc
abwehr zentrum und das österreichische
bundesheer
[Applaus]
[Musik]
es spricht nun die vom bundesministerium
für landesverteidigung magistra klaudia
tanner
sehr geehrter herr abgeordneter zum
europäischen parlament alexander huber
sehr geehrter herr abgeordneter gibt und
bürgermeister in vertretung unserer
landeshauptfrau lieber christian sie hat
der generalstabschefs stellvertreterin
rainer rudolf striedinger sehr geehrte
frau präsidentin hatte staatsanwalt sehr
geehrte herren
militärattachés sehr geehrter herr
oberst schlechter
kommandanten und kommandanten sehr
geehrte ehrengäste damen und herren
vereinbar und ganz besonders am heutigen
tag sehr geehrte soldatinnen und
soldaten
und zivilbedienstete das abc
abwehrzentrums
ganz schlechte hat schon erwähnt da
heutige tag
dieses datum der sechsundzwanzigster
bilder ist nicht zufällig gewählt
sondern er hat mit dem jahrestag des
bislang größten unfalles in einem
kernkraftwerk
zu tun bei dem weite teile von europa
verstrahlt wurden ja auch in österreich
und sehr viele von ihnen sehr geehrte
damen und herren können sich noch daran
erinnern als eine radioaktive wolke
österreich erreichte am nachmittag des
diesen tag schlug aber auch die stunde
da pc spezialisten des österreichischen
bundesheeres denn es war wohl ein
beispielloser
assistenzeinsatz in dem die soldaten
unermüdlich im einsatz waren ständige
messungen die fanzonen waren abzugrenzen
und einen staatsgrenzen war das
abspielen von personenfahrzeugen und
zügen
zu tun um
kontamination verschleppungen zu
minimieren wir dürfen sehr geehrte damen
und herren nicht vergessen dass das
durchaus unter einsatz der eigenen
gesundheit auch geschah
ja und seitdem sind mittlerweile
36 jahre vergangen
in der zwischenzeit haben sich unsere
soldatinnen und soldaten und
zivilbediensteten das abc abwehrzentrums
nicht nur national sondern auch
international einen hervorragenden ruf
erworben unsere spezialisten sind immer
einsatzbereit und sie gehören weltweit
wohl zu den besten ihres faches das
zeigt auch der spruch
die austrians ja immer wieder ertönt
inzwischen hat sich der ba ca für
schulen nicht nur von ihrem standort her
geändert und ist von wien übersiedelt in
die ducks kaserne sondern sie ist auch
umbenannt worden nach der physikerin
lise meitner
aber eines ist geblieben die tradition
sehr geehrte damen und herren die ist
geblieben und ich denke gerade in diesem
fachgebiet sieht man alles was wollen
hinkunft noch viel wichtiger werden wird
man sieht wie eng das militärische mit
dem zivilen verknüpft ist und ich freue
mich dass so viele persönlichkeiten
heute hier sind aus dem zivilen bereich
wir müssen uns eines vor augen halten
dass atomare biologische und chemische
kampfmittel ja sofort auch auswirkungen
zeigen auf die zivilbevölkerung das
heißt eine gute abwehr ist eines sie ist
essentiell
gerade
seit dieser nacht bis 24 februar des
beginns des angriffskrieges putins auf
die ukraine ist diese weltweit
anerkannte kompetenz dieser
waffengattung für den schutz der
menschen in österreich von ganz
besonderer bedeutung
es ist national wie international ein
unverzichtbares element doch und
instrument doch der katastrophenhilfe es
wurde schon erwähnt die leistungen die
erbracht worden sind in zusammenhang mit
der bekämpfung der korona pandemie an
die vielen unterstützungsleistungen die
im postverteilzentrum
inhalten ins tor vom in anderen
einrichtungen erbracht worden sind
denken wir an die elf vom herrn
kommandanten schon erwähnten zahlreichen
inlands und
auslandseinsätze der
katastrophenhilfe einheit achtung in den
vergangenen jahr eine unglaubliche
bandbreite die von der rettung und
bergung von verschütteten über die
wasseraufbereitung bis zu weiteren
humanitären
hilfeleistungen bei technischen und
naturkatastrophen reichte
diese einsetzung der ruf der
erworben wurde das geht nicht ohne
entsprechende ausbildung und als eine
der bildungseinrichtung des
österreichischen bundesheeres wird ja
auch die verantwortung getragen für die
grund für die ford aber auch für die
weiterbildung von offizieren von
unteroffizieren und taschen im
fachbereich abc abwehr ein
kompetenzzentrum im besten sinne wo
einsatz wo leere wo weiterentwicklung
zusammentreffen und diese kompetenz sehr
geehrte damen und herren wie spiegelt
sich dann für die bevölkerung oft auch
im medienauftritten unserer experten
wieder wenn es darum geht das so
unvorstellbare und unfassbare zu
erklären nämlich kriege kriege in
anderen ländern um den einsatz und die
folgewirkungen des einsatzes von
chemischen biologischen und atomen
kampfstoffen
sehr geehrte damen und herren
insbesondere das abc abwehrzentrums
soldatinnen und soldaten
es ist mir ein bedürfnis ihnen danke zu
sagen danke zu sagen für ihren einsatz
für ihr engagement für ihre
einsatzbereitschaft und das sehr oft
unter kurzen vorwarnzeiten
seien sie sich gewiss sie sind
unverzichtbar
sie sind für das österreichische
bundesheer
unentbehrlich mit ihren einsätzen haben
sie bewiesen beweisen sie immer wieder
dass sie eine unverzichtbare funktion im
intakten zusammenleben der menschen
haben das gibt uns allen der damen und
herren sicherheit das schützt unsere
bevölkerung ich wünsche ihnen alles
erdenklich gute für die zukunft für alle
bevorstehenden aufgaben und
herausforderungen
alles gute viel erfolg und soldatenglück
es lebe das abc abwehrzentrum es lebe
das österreichische bundesheer es lebe
die republik österreich
dankeschön
[Applaus]
frau bundesminister ich darf sie bieten
gleich hier zu bleiben
wir kommen nun zu einigen auszeichnungen
und ehrungen und dazu biete ich auch den
kommandanten des hbc abwehrzentrums zu
mir
es erfolgt nun die ernennung zu
ehrenmitgliedern und ich bitte den
präsidenten des vereins forum abc abwehr
zu uns
zu ehrenmitgliedern des vereins forum
abc abwehr werden ernannt amtsdirektorin
ruhe regierungsrat karl staaten holzer
oberrad außer dienst dr johannes rising
und oberstes meister thomas rakowitz ich
bitte die drei herren zum rednerpult
[Musik]
ich freue mich sehr ernst direkt was ich
denke
mit beschluss vom 25
jena 22 wurde ihnen das barfuß mit
ich freue mich sehr dass ich ihnen
mitteilen dass drinnen mit beschluss vom
22 jahren im winter gibt es warum abc
abwehr zuerkannt worden ist und ich wir
können dazu
als nächstes erfolgt die verleihung des
verwendung abzeichens für das
fachpersonal der abc abwehr an die
angehörigen der abc hatte komponist
starb spartans 3 und ich bitte nun zum
rednerpult leitmann stefan pauls
wachtmeister ibm hat ein wachtmeister
johannes rauch wachtmeister ivan
markovic und wachtmeister manuel redner
ich stehe heute wir freuen uns dass wir
ihnen das verwendung für das
fachpersonal der abc abwehr verleihen
dürfen ich dafür nicht dazu ganz
herzlich gratulieren
wachtmeister übernehmen aber gehe freue
mich dass wir das verwendung für das
macht ganz normalen pc auch wer
verleihen können hat sich die
kooperation
ja macht meine mama ist auch es wird
ihnen hiermit wasserverwendung abzeichen
für die trachtler abc abwehr berlin wir
dürfen wir dazu ganz herzlich
gratulieren
[Applaus]
der wachtmeister markwitz ich freue mich
sehr dass wir ihnen das verwendung
abzeichen für das fachpersonal da
beziehen auch wer verleihen dürfen alles
gute
[Applaus]
herr wachtmeister manuel reitmeier
wir dürfen das verwendung abzeichen für
das wachpersonal mit
ihnen ganz herzlich gratulieren
wir kommen nun zu verleihen oder einsatz
und erinnerungsmedaille cobit 19 durch
die verbundes ministerin an den
kommandanten des arbeitsjahres zentrums
das ist eine ganz besondere freude dass
waren jedoch einsätze im assistenz
bereich im unterstützungsbereich in
zusammenhang mit der bekämpfung der
pandemie alles andere als üblich war es
gab in wahrheit keine blaupause ist kann
auch keine blaupause für die sehr
einsatzmedaille des österreichischen
bundesheeres aber es ist mir ein
bedürfnis ist eine ganz besondere freude
ihnen herr oberst schlechter in
würdigung ihrer leistungen die sie im
rahmen des assistenzeinsatzes 19 nach §
2 absatz 1 zurückziehen deswegen setze
2001 unter erheblicher physischer und
psychischer belastung erbracht haben
ihnen gewisse bestimmungen des wdr
auszeichnungs gesetzes 2002
warum diese einzelmedaillen des
österreichischen bundesheeres verein
alles gute
nicht nur stolz
meine damen und herren wir kommen nun
zum abschluss und höhepunkt
ich freue mich sehr oberst jürgen
schlechter in würdigung seines
engagements aber bekämpfung der pandemie
gegen kobe 19 stimmen dass der last von
24 29 21 19 erinnerungsmedaille des
österreichischen bundesheeres übergeben
verbunden mit den besten
und jetzt zum höhepunkt und abschluss
kommen wir noch zu einer verleihung des
goldenen ehrenzeichens mit entschließung
des herrn bundespräsidenten wird für ein
oberrad ddr johannes reisinger das
goldene ehrenzeichen für verdienste um
die republik österreich verliehen
auszeichnung anerkennung die eine super
streich das mehr an leistungen erbracht
worden sind es das was eigentlich
notwendig ist und das zu jeder tages und
nachtzeit
es ist mir es ist uns eine ganz
besondere freude die urkunde zur
verlesung bringen zu dürfen und das
goldene ehrenzeichen überreichen zu
dürfen
die präsidentschaftskanzlei beurkundet
hiermit dass bundespräsident dr leksand
farben mit entschließung vom 21 jänner
20 22 jahren oberrad in ruhe dr johannes
reisinger das goldene ehrenzeichen für
verdienste um die republik österreich
verliehen hat gezeigt vom kabinetts vize
direktor markus lange verbunden mit
meiner allerbesten wünsche zu dieser
besonderen auszeichnung
mit dem ertönen egoistischen landes
schwimmen der bitte um beiträge fehl und
dem ausmaß der ehrenformation wird
dieser festakt beendet
die
presse
niederösterreichischen auf das haben wir
das ganze red
[Musik]
das ganze
wäre zu schön
das ganze parade
das ganze hab
schon
ihre
pressemeldungen hat die frau
bundesminister das ganze red
frau bundesministerin ad hoc meldung die
beendigung des festaktes und fitter und
weitere befehlen fiel nach für diesen zu
würdigen festakt abrücken lassen
abrücken lassen
das ganze habe
er schon
das ganze parade
das ganze
[Musik]
viren zu schützen
tipp
feldzeichen aus der spielzeit er
informationen einblenden
das ganze red
das ganze
schule
das ganze parade
hat er zog er hat formation übernehmen
abdrücken
meines meine sehr verehrten
das ganze hab
zum abrücken der information das ganze
recht
[Musik]